there's one thing I want to ask you
about this is my one of my favorite
fortnite controversies oh really yeah
what was it's not really about fortnite
but there was uh I mean you probably
even putting the wall about this it was
just I know you guys might not know
about this I was this kid uh who was in
the FaZe Clan called Java oh I don't
know about that so what he did was he
had the you know because content was
running a little dry he had the big
brain idea of what if I made a video
where I downloaded an Aimbot and showed
off an Aimbot in like normal like oh
yeah
it was like a it was like a cultural
moment it wasn't just a fortnight it was
huge you know cheating was rampant but
he went into like a normal non-ranked
game I think and just showed off what it
was like and what these tutors were
using right yeah and then he got a
lifetime ban from permanent band
he was also like he was like what like
17. yeah it was yeah yeah yeah and he
made a video like crying and it was very
and a lot of people felt like
obviously you're a [__] idiot but
yeah I think it's like a double standard
thing right it was usually because if
they made the exception for him because
he is Young and he is popular
he was good at the game he was hacking
to show a point or make a funny video
whatever
but it's like where do you draw the line
then on like other people's band appeals
and stuff like that it was a tough spot
for epic to be in I would have unbanned
him but
you know they could have also banned him
and had a time limit on it which was
also another option but I think it's
just like the usual thing is a hardware
IP ban every person but I would say the
one argument I have against that is
usually because most people who are
banned do not have their identity
attached to it yeah they do are they are
able to get around it yeah yeah but he
was like it's not just like he couldn't
make fortnite videos anymore he would
get sued yeah even if he like made the
video and like you know didn't show the
character name or made a new account
every time I made a video he would get
sued like so he had absolutely no choice
I think I think yeah he probably should
have been unbanned but how did a bit of
a [__] did they get resolved or no and
you know credit to him he's found ways
to Pivot throughout the years but it's
just a shame because he
he was good he was popping off he was
going crazy yeah huge news when it
happened I remember it was and then
everyone had an opinion because it was
as everyone does on Twitter it's a good
story
whether they should or shouldn't this
I've got thoughts on this yeah I mean
like I I think I saw this on a clip like
somewhere on some person like explaining
it and I mean it seemed like he was very
sorry about it but I gave him okay
she was very very sorry about it but I
don't know it was a [__] dumb thing
to do yeah it's kind of like I guess in
in my field like I would it would be
like hey there's this website that you
can do to watch anime like illegally by
the way I'm just showing it off not
because I promote it but yeah let me
just show it off yeah let me just show
it off the watches are yeah yeah let me
just show it off to all my viewer base
yeah yeah yeah
you know what I mean like that's like no
difference it's just like putting a
mountain of cocaine on the table being
like you see this this is bad
well I think it's like an interesting
thought I think of this with a lot of
YouTube controversy where people do
something dumb it's like there is a
feedback loop that happens on YouTube
yep and like say I use Logan Paul's
example they're not comparable
situations but I would say large amounts
of the time you're making content you
get a positive response you go a little
bit more extreme with that content you
do something more outlandish you go a
little bit more wild with it yeah more
of a positive response the more extreme
the video the more extreme emotions
you're engaging more extreme the views
response I'd say with like Logan and his
foresting obviously horrible thing to do
but up until that every time he did
something crazy getting constantly like
positive feedback everyone on Twitter
even honestly in general I would say at
the time he was in YouTube Rewind he was
the face of YouTube at the time he was
getting four 500 million views a month
I'm not saying whether he was doing the
right thing all the time I'm there was a
good chunk of people who on the internet
who were not a fan though even before
that I think that was like the yes this
he finally yeah it was like a full
opposite ends of the spectrum for sure
but I'd say even the bubble he was in I
was saying like well he could be a bad
person anyway I'm just saying that like
for that thing he was constantly going
crazy or getting more good results from
it yeah I don't think he started out
saying this is a great idea this is
where I want to end up you know and
obviously it's very different to the
Java situation but I would say in
fortnite at the time like oh yeah people
who were doing videos of like catching a
hacker or something like that you're
getting all these positive responses
that makes it so you don't fully
consider all the potential outcomes for
what you're actually creating especially
like it's it's always interesting to see
when a video gets posted or when you
know your own kind of content and your
own kind of character gets judged to an
audience that's outside of your
established audience as well yeah
because you sometimes you don't
sometimes you get kind of a reality
check uh especially you know with
someone like Logan Paul or someone on
that size where you you get the feedback
that you don't normally expect yeah you
know and you you get they can be healthy
obviously like yeah yeah yeah there was
also another video that came out not too
long ago that was kind of similar uh but
I guess very different in delivery and
purpose uh there was a guy who did a
video about off and shooting in tarkov
and he in the video he downloaded an
Aimbot and he was trying to find other
people who were also using a name Bob
and it was really kind of compelling
because there was those moments where
the two Aimbot dudes could see each
other through walls and stuff they were
like noticing each other and giving each
other and they'd be like don't shoot me
I'm also involved don't shoot someone
else we're friends yeah yeah and he was
kind of like documenting it was a really
good video and it kind of threw that
Community into like after all because
they were like what the [__] yeah I
don't let's see like I think there's
been so many videos I've scrapped
because I'm like oh epic might not like
this or this Game Dev might not like I
guess that's also a way where the
Creator code or maybe the skin has a
little bit of power I would say I would
say for sure
um but I I think this just you know how
far can I push it before I get like in
trouble of Epic or something we did this
video where we played old versions of
fortnite that people sort of like
re-uploaded and remade and you're like
we worked out after a while you're fine
to do it long as you don't do the
multiplayer one or you don't use skins
because they don't want it to be like
people can place other fortnite where
you're not buying skins
so it ended up being fine but it was
like there's a line here and we're here
have you ever been contacted or been
told like epic games told me told me to
take videos down here oh yeah I was
doing like a glitch or some [__] and
they'd be like yeah and I was like look
I love you whatever you want fair enough
because like it was actually something
they just couldn't fix for a while yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it was like game
breaking
uh so it was I think at the time you
could fly a helicopter or something well
above the hype barrier so you could just
get a bunch of meds at the start of the
game just sit up there and just heal
without anyone no other player could
even see you right right you sit up
there you'd Win Every Game you uploaded
the video doing that yeah yeah
well because it
race bro
I used to sleep like two or three hours
a night at my own video like I try and
like sometimes weep as I'm going to
sleep but I had no moisture in miles I
couldn't cry it was a [__] grind you
were in a concert hustle to get that
stuff out I didn't have time to think of
like oh is epic gonna like this glitch
yeah I mean they like make fix your bugs
you know they ask nicely I'm like fair
enough that's reasonable like they
explain why I'm like I'm waiting for the
laser beam apology video in like two
years sorry I didn't mean it sorry for
hacking your game bro
um but yeah I mean like
do you play other games outside of the
games you make content around
um I play I still play a little bit of
RuneScape I had a real phase at the
start of this year and the last year I
would say well classic uh dragonfly came
out the the new expansion I did do
classic burning Crusade for a bit
um I just don't like other people so I
can't read well I guess socially anxious
so I don't like I feel that's their
children right unless yeah unless I can
get the children the [__] bully if I
could just pay money to be better than
me but like Saudi Prince win their game
you know I I ain't beating like Illidan
with like like a couple V bucks or
something you know I can't just pay you
some money
um so yeah like raiding like intimidated
me so I didn't I didn't keep playing
what else do I play other players still
a little sports games play a lot of
Crusader Kings uh like the strategy
games I love that [__]
um been playing Super Auto pets a lot
lately shout outs mobile games uh what
else do I play
honestly like it's either hardcore
strategy games
I love strategy games or uh yeah quite
literally just playing a sports game or
some kind probably yeah FIFA all right
the good old days man yeah it's really
hard to make videos on strategy games
though oh it's it's really tough but
some people do make some great questions
there's another Aussie who does and he
does like factorio videos oh I haven't
seen that unfortunately it sounds like
I'm missing out and they're really good
because factorio is probably the most
boring [__] game in the world but
some people can make [__] so compelling
yeah they just make it into a good
narrative and it just works I forgot the
guy's name he's very funny um he just
like just cause speed runs but honestly
speed runs are like 70 hour runs [__]
you know in one go insane humans yeah
insane humans actually just another
level of insanity you mentioned earlier
as well that you know when you started
out maybe you do now you had imposter
syndrome but obviously right now you're
at like it's worse yeah a high level
like does it yeah I mean how does that
come into effect with slowing down
making content or do you second guess
yourself a lot more I think that is
um I think when you're in a Rhythm
um it's easy to just keep going yeah and
you don't think like you still have
imposter syndrome but like you don't
you're still just in a rhythm yeah yeah
when you sort of take because a bunch of
[__] happened in my life in 2021 that
was sort of the reason to take a step
back yeah yeah um [__] that was outside
my control unfortunately but yeah life's
fine now but it sort of broke that
Rhythm a little bit and all of a sudden
when you're out of that Rhythm you start
overthinking videos a little bit and
you're like I know what you mean I know
yeah yeah and then you get like a eight
out of ten and I know maybe I'm not as
good as I thought I don't know it's
crazy uh it also just comes down to like
a lot of shit's quite boring in gaming
right now I would say unfortunately
there's nothing that really makes me too
enthusiastic yeah so I feel like if I'm
not fully believing in the video it's
not worth it it's not worth it even
though people just like saying you have
fun just do something well it sucks
right because you kind of get that you
kind of get like a false alarm because
sometimes you get some videos that just
feel so right and it works perfectly
yeah and then you're like damn but this
other video just doesn't just doesn't
feel like that and it's like well that's
what having a job is yeah yeah not
relying on that high of getting
everything perfect it's it's having to
force yourself when the idea is maybe
not as good as it could be to either
make it better or just power through and
make it decent yeah yeah but is that not
like I would say
some of the massive privilege that comes
with like perhaps you have some previous
success oh absolutely and there isn't
that like dual die like when I was
leaving the job site it's like it's this
or I have [__] no idea what I'm doing
right yeah you are you are just whatever
it takes whereas now you have choices I
can go be in other people's videos I
could do this I could like not upload a
video I couldn't I could not I could
honestly not awkward but I still love it
I'm still obsessed with it so it's like
you don't have to do stuff you don't
necessarily want to do which is massive
privilege but it does lead to that like
you know paralysis like decision
paralysis yeah yeah especially when you
start doubting yourself with like am I
as good as I used to be like well people
don't like me anymore like oh but yeah
have you ever thought about doing things
outside of just like you know gaming
videos like because obviously you do
like a lot of challenges with games
right now but you definitely have like
the resources to do like wild and wacky
yeah like you can do like while like IRL
stuff yeah that's what like my ignorance
unfortunately come into this like I I
knew a lot of you guys from like I was
saying to Alex I'm like oh they're the
anime guys right
and that's like my ignorance I apologize
you're not wrong like there's a lot of
like Origins there but you've like sort
of expanded into other things yeah yeah
I think um definitely like I I mean I
I've done pretty much everything that
can be done like sitting on your
computer like yeah right any sort of
react stuff streaming gaming whatever it
is and like I said when I was doing real
world stuff it was very more Vlog style
yeah but I think it is definitely like a
goal of mine this year especially I've
done a lot of stuff with the sidemen who
do a lot of like all they do is yeah
that's crazy yeah all they do is the
real world stuff and I think it's just
it's just fun I'm like I don't really
care okay
like I've been there done that when it
comes to getting views it's not really
about that I suppose yeah yeah filming
now it'd just be cool I think it'd be
cool little thing to see so I'm
definitely trying but we'll see yeah
because I feel like they're I I don't
know there's a feel I feel like you
would be so entertaining to do to see
you guys just like see you just doing
challenges IRL instead of just maybe
instead of bullying kids it's funny
though
I had an idea
it was a YouTube show because I didn't
know how to thumbnail but it's like
someone kills me in fortnite shop at the
house
okay you want to [__] go and
statistically they're probably like 15.
yeah I'd probably let's box and match
there's also a chance I show up as a big
bikie or something like yeah yeah it
kills me which would be equally
entertaining uh not for me